como é que você ainda tem coragem de
falar comigo e aí galera campeonato bom
você e já vou avisando no começo do
vídeo que sábado agora de 27 o show em
recife no teatro dos guararapes a demora
não fazer propaganda no show tem que
fazer com agosto em comprar mais carros
para mim então recife sábado agora dia
27 de fevereiro no teatro guararapes 18
horas o ingresso no primeiro link na
descrição do vídeo garanhões dia 28 é
nóis valeu o dia 4 5 e 6 em brasília um
dos bancários comprar ingresso no mesmo
link só clicar aqui embaixo valeu o
herói foi no cinema assistir de lipo
além dela e por já sangrou eu perdi o
filme em 3d
vou me dar uma facada na rota facada o é
doida sangue de marcha rumo era tanto
sangue que não sabia se era um filme era
a primeira menstruação da minha irmã que
é o grupo da apple ele não é um super
herói é um justiceiro o que é o super
herói super herói álbum balé o cara faz
tudo para matar ninguém e não quer matar
ele quer justiça e pode matar tem que
fazer o bem do justiceiro você quer
matar sequer a liminar do juiz sequer
sofrem o juiz ele quer esmagar o cheiro
que machucar um justiceiro ele quer ver
sofreu seja pablo pablo é um justiceiro
a um palestino frank pavone aquele vidro
eles cooptando em fazer uma proposta e
deixar mais forte agora faz uma proposta
a ele meu jovem apareça agora essa
doença você tem isso aqui se quer fazer
e ele vai ouvir o claro que acabou então
para que o processo é assim tem que
provocar dor no cara muita dor muita dor
para poder que foi ao seu poder de em
uma dessas torturas e lhe desfigurou o
rosto inteiro a pele dele fica toda
enrugada homem vira um monstro a mais
feia da terra inclusive eu queria deixar
que os parabéns a regina casé tratou
muito bem ter página casa é ver porque
eu sou abit alguma coisa interessante
aquela mulher ele chega a rebentar
todo mundo comenta nem a televisão
o grupo esquenta e eles se regenera o
filme já começa com muita pancadaria sim
e muito tiro tiro muita facada muito
murro carvalho leva um tiro no cu cara
leva um tiro no cu lp é só tarefa um
tiro num encontro de trabalho não rola
no clube e estava um tiro nem água nem
quero outro vai levar pedrada no cuja
obra revela um tiro a sorte é que ele se
regenera então cuba regina vai ficar bem
virgin coladinho assim mas na geral com
o filme tem aquele cara que é de aço do
tipo todo cromado do ex membro tem
aquele cara que tem uma mulher também é
muito forte gol e macho tem hora que os
dois vão brigar aí você literalmente ver
a força da mulher o gigante de ferro vem
correndo
a gata recebe algo comum embora vivendo
que é muito é muito bem humorado a cena
muito fora que fomos tão bem dado mas
tão linda como uma linha do mundo ou
muito bem dar foi muito bonito mas que
ainda têm pressionado ainda curtir no
culpará e do débito de manhã eu acho que
todo curtem muito acho que todo custo
uma rede wifi com o amiguinho junto a
você na hora que o cara levou um tiro no
curso e motor infecção
todo mundo sentiu junto carrega ter sido
a do medronho meu dedo seok o filme em
3d quando levou um tiro no cool é [ __ ]
porque sangue já é nojento agora sangue
de culpa o outro tiro que não tem muitos
já não o filme não sabia se era eu era
um absorvente usa sangue falta sangue
falso e falsidade um site que você conta
seu segredo ele conta por outro samba
acabou o filme não conseguir parar de
pensar que tinha no currículo cuidar do
ele mandou um chute nos ovos que vai
votar a questão que é que dói mais um
chute nos jogos onde no começo aqui
embaixo que você acha que dói mais você
vai gostar desse vídeo já sabe fazer é
só clicar em gostei aqui nesse vídeo no
youtube vai ajudar demais vou ficar
muito feliz vai ter muito mais vídeo
volta lá no facebook eu postei esse
vídeo e 19 desse jeito você clique em
curtir e marca seu amigo que já assistiu
o filme que não assistiu ainda vai
assistir para seus amigos comentário não
se esquece galera de recife teatro
guararapes sábado dia 27 18 horas de
garanhões domingo dia 4 5 e 6 em
brasília é nóis valeu pai eu tiro no cu
de vocês